nestled between rolling hills and rustic
vineyards I've come to the village of
Aqaba population 800
this is Germany's wine country near the
border to France
I'm here to meet 20 year old Alexander
Simha
he's one of 11,000 people in Germany who
need an organ transplant to survive such
team 740 ever for now this is what keeps
Alex alive he has to carry the device
with him everywhere he goes it regulates
a pump implanted in his heart that's why
achievements Oh Emma and Scoville always
just come down to alarm okay when the
heart of Lucas now we dime sticker good
come on this is good a tiny Ferguson
what is has such donation club finished
fixed - Anya the gun Simon get one from
yet to start Ashford and escanso visitor
so for Kaiser these batteries power
Alex's heart pump it gets the
electricity it needs from a cable
running through his abdomen smashing on
you ash my lava jato a Chinese mask
phooey when you party Nixon to IBM so
art of alcohol just I'm Jamie community
but they are so beautiful i Scott was
Festa ha
and given that Martin I've understood
see one I'm closer to such naughty tree
itself from the pool the pump lies don't
rush hour struck soaked was it's dying
was it's here Lucifer was first
immediate Misawa
if anything happens to Alex's support
system his organs won't get the oxygen
they need and his body will shut down
Alec still lives at home when he was
first put on the waiting list for a new
heart back in 2013 his family wasn't
prepared for what was in store huh
binder from his elbow tank this kid
question el Appa harnessed and belayed
all of whom on some doctor this is mr.
Fuji Aki and it's it's to know my heart
apart I looked up some stuff myself to
come forward after his first pump nearly
caused Alex to have a stroke he now has
to take around a dozen pills a day to
prevent further complications
leaving the house requires careful
preparation this is just one of the many
precautions alex has had to incorporate
into his daily life if anything happens
to his heart device if water or dust
gets inside the battery pack his life
could be in serious danger like many
people in the area Alex works on a
vineyard but only part-time and only
when the weather allows it all that
would take is just one slip in the mud
one bad fall and the machine keeping him
alive
could stop working even on a good day he
can only handle a few hours in the job
it's avatar guilt in here
shut up on me to stay apply that and
look taller and I got an abscess
my name is as real as possible didn't
mean it is equal to bias Rock master
stuff all actors fighter just drive the
car above its lights a small basically a
hard drive icon I hope is the co-edit on
most oh I'm like a medium gonzo sukhiya
just cans emulsification Alex is one of
11,000 people in Germany waiting for an
organ transplant but the number of
people donating their organs is much
lower in recent years it's even gone
down that's even though 70% of Germans
say they support organ donation in
theory
as humor mention lavash Kanaka thank me
when I told my aunt we might eat be
multi Oh Canada thank this with the
whole concern for quotes in Vilas in the
median does we bother making cleaning
was nice all relief material and some
other sake for subcommittee Helen
organic almonds of us on this finger
Smithers deselect nearly as often Jordan
finished up your printer to understand
the mining battle was forbidden and kept
me ever known each time at the Nelson
and I go sites becoming an organ donor
in Germany is easy all you have to do is
get one of these an organ donors card
there are available lots of places
including pharmacies if more people had
these cards it would save lives
three people died in Germany every day
waiting for a transplant
in a tiny town like this one the
volunteer fire department is the
backbone of many people's social lives
Alex had trained to rescue people if a
building was on fire he would have been
one of the first inside now he's had to
take a back seat he tries to help out by
coordinating information for the fire
crew thanks Romano serenity Cole
evidences for hearts full million
devices sadly Messiah never
this may be just a drill but with all
the action I start to wonder how safe it
is for Alex and his heart support system
he forced our life ladies out our
darkest alder weakness before her
applause I'm going for our system I'm so
sorry sorry on for indicator where the
[ __ ] I hope they will know it's it's
always a favor
hopefully some sticker
alex has no idea how much longer he'll
have to wait to get a new heart but
clearly he's determined to stay alive
for now it's goodbye
but I'll be checking in on him again
soon